money really is the energy which fuels  your life people don't understand that  if you do not have access to your money  if you're not free to use your money as  you wish you really can't participate in  society whether it's choosing what car  you want to drive whether it's choosing  how much meat you want to eat all these  different things is when they control  the money they literally control you in  America for example they're trying to  ban the Second Amendment we don't really  need to ban the Second Amendment  necessarily in order to stop people  buying it you just control their money  and so they can't then go ahead and buy  a gun so if you control the money you  really control every aspect of a  person's life